[Music]
right now we're living through a
full-fledged crisis in our democracy now
there are not tanks in the streets but
what's happening right now goes to the
heart of who we are as a nation
and I say this not as a Democrat who
lost an election but as an American
afraid of losing a country so as a
general matter if you watch the show you
know we don't cover Hillary Clinton
because she said and we feel sorry for
her for real but then she showed up at
Yale which as you know is one of the
most impressive places in the world with
some of the smartest kids on the planet
obviously we're very impressed by Yale
they invited her to be the commencement
speaker and so we kind of have to cover
it
during her totally not bitter at all
address Clinton pulled out a Russian hat
because she's hilarious
and said quote if you can't beat them
join them cuz that's not a cliche of
course we could never beat author and
columnist mark Stein at analyzing this
behavior so we're outsourcing it to him
so our hands are clean we're not being
mean to Hillary Clinton who deserves our
pity we're letting mark Stein explain it
for us hey Mark hey Chuck I love the way
that Hillary is now doing visual comedy
she's disappointed she didn't get to be
president by the way I like it when you
do a visual gag that you explain it what
you're meant to find funny about it to
the audience before her so when she said
this is a Russian hat
I think obviously she said a loose end
doesn't know what to do I think Vladimir
Putin should make her chief commissar of
State Approved jokes in Moscow I think
she's eminently qualified for it as
personally would have preferred it by
the by the way I do actually think this
is the actual Russian hat that Russian
intelligence agents left the fusion GPS
dossier under for Christopher's steel to
find in a men's room on the cooter
versity prospect in Moscow you're not
normally it's not normally mi6
tradecraft to take the Hat but he
thought it might make a nice souvenir
for Chelsea unfortunately she'd already
been given one by the rain
one guy so she gave this Russian hat to
her mother which is very thoughtful for
my own part I think it would have been a
much more effective routine if she
warned the the shoe bar which has been
worn as you know by Macedonian content
farmers the Macedonian content farmers
who costs are the election or perhaps to
establish our authority the traditional
cow SIA originally worn by Alexander the
Great if I recall my school days and
still favored by Macedonian content farm
overseas when they want the masses to
care and terror before them so I felt
she made it poor like many women at the
royal wedding on Saturday she made a
poor headgear choice for this occasion I
knew that you could bring mirth out of
one of the saddest most heartbreaking
moments I'd seen in a long time do you
think being honest here for a second
being too sincere do you think Yael is
aware of how thoroughly it degrades its
own already eroding reputation by
inviting someone like this to be the
commencement speaker well yeah I do
think as a serious matter that parties
and politicians when they're invited to
give commencement addresses should not
talk about partisan electoral politics I
mentioned Chelsea a moment ago for some
reason Chelsea gets paid seven or she
did before November 2016 she got paid
seven-figure sums to deliver speeches on
diarrhea in Africa it would have I
wouldn't want to hear a speech on
diarrhea in Africa for commencement but
I think that's actually more seemly and
appropriate for the economy unless less
dirty than what we saw mark Stein a
genius self-evidently thank you great to
see you thanks a lot tucker